welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I am joined by James Dean who is the
head of the isp team within hamilton
Barnes know that yes I'm joined by James
Dean tonight thank you for coming in
James thanks having me come in that has
been isn't that so if you don't know
James actually works for as I said
Hamilton Barnes and I've already done an
episode with George Barnes and I think
I'll pull it out there straight away but
when we spoke and when I did the episode
with George he said and him and James
were neck-and-neck who is gonna be the
top biller for them lashing Jones gonna
inform us how that how that planned out
but yeah James let you know we're always
always like to start how how did you
enter the world of recruitment me a lot
most people didn't grow up and once
become a recruiter yeah I didn't go to
school one day but I did always want to
work in the city I like a clear plan me
my jake Smith we used to say to everyone
who wanted to do accountants or
mechanical engineering yeah we just
wanted to work in the city we didn't
know what that was
we just wanted to work on their money
and wage from where are you from both
from Essex okay so in school and Bentley
small town in Essex so as of the age of
like thirteen fourteen she wanted to
work in an office when sales people got
paid good money yeah and then fast
forward after college I've got a sales
job that was just doing like medias
house really pretty
how did you get into that just it's one
of my mates Jack he got a job there it
was a twenty one grand a year it was
local so I got the job there I did that
for a beer I might a few other jobs on
yes Donald Forrest in it as well and I
had an interview at McDonald's I didn't
get a job all right
I loved it too few folks be hired like
my best mates on one shift it was nice
going there first
really shame they didn't do a referral
so no yeah what's this media place and
New York Jackie was a bit of a laugh and
which I didn't like it from the start
was there a couple of months but even
like the top salesmen were just like
very
I'm motivating very uninspiring and I
had this image of salespeople really
cool yeah they weren't that at all so I
started looking at recruitment jobs and
I got told that if I went to V Festival
that weekend I was gonna get sacked from
the job really can't hit my quota as I
it was ridiculous it was selling it was
like Yellow Pages near typically for the
motoring industry so I used to call them
up and try this big sales pitch that I
call portion prim and proper and
apparently I was just too salesy I was
new like I was so articulate I was just
like all the guys that are doing well
was really establishing this job I've
got this media space you did say anyway
no obviously I didn't really like it so
I was totally if I didn't go back in on
the Friday I see it I could kiss my job
goodbye yeah so um so looking at other
jobs it was a guy that I know leaked
like his name is he's a few years older
than me
it's one of my sister's mates good
friend like all of his family he's got
problem my age as well and he works in
recruitment and he was quite a dream so
I didn't actually speak to my boss
people just knew as I said he works in
recruitment I really and I really looked
up to TVA's quite a cool guy hope he
doesn't listen sis so then yeah I just
applied like mad side applying for
recruitment really went back from my
lunch break I too miss course one was
from a guy called Sean everyone was lady
Cara and I called the guy back first and
he goes ah well do you know anything
about recruitment no you can money and
yeah he was a wreck to wreck yeah and he
was like I said this is what it is from
start to finish Tommy everything okay
great and he was going to get me loads
of job opportunities you gave me loads
of interview never heard back for him
Sean the irony sure missed on the juice
little fee there and then I called kora
back I know name's Cora hot yeah she was
the internal recruiter for a comedy
called Jam recruitment and uh she call
me back I called her back from the
missed call and you know she's missed
you of course already know about crewmen
oh no see that's how Sean how it out man
yeah so it gets even better story so I
went in for the interview did this big
panel interview with Jack
and I died for never gonna get a job
there was all these guys in there they
were like when you say panel Jimmy in
life like an assessment center all right
assessment yeah and you had all the the
senior bosses the big one choice who
says the line president basically yeah
yeah no I just did loads research in the
company so any chance I've got to go I
know this about economy like this all
you put this online
yeah so point out for me a bit annoying
and then I've got taken through to next
next stage of interviewing and it was
only me and I had four guys left and me
and his chap ollie
we've gone really really well to sell
ourselves back to sell the other person
sorry back to the group really so he was
joking fun of her I am yeah yeah and
obviously I'm like I'm in the suit I
bought from Asda these guys well I
travelled the world they're all way over
into this university I'm like real bad
acting its point as well so there's a
spot you know I senior from has done me
an ollie just here off we were joking as
I this isn't gonna work but I pitched
him he pitched me he had a really funny
story excused to work at festivals yeah
doing Lauren yeah I was getting called
back in I was like I can't go to a
festival I know I know they're always
come back in Tuesday so I turned up
thinking all cured I've missed the
interview they're gonna have a go at me
I walked in and Nick was all how was I
was the festival in was he good sauce
ask me all these questions are the fest
Mike he actually cared a begin to know
yeah and I what's going on here this is
what works meant to be like yeah and and
then I had done a role play who's George
yeah and they suffer by George Barnes
who Nick and jaws now own Hamill bonds
here listening and who don't know and a
cockle bridge they just hammered me and
I was a mess I'm shaking really but what
I'm going to do how like this like blog
proper put you on the spot on that so
about pitching a candidate at some of
the pitch was and then they told me the
scenario said Nick was on holiday and
and George was going to do the
interviews if I asked so I called up
pitching this candidates Nick and the
excited on the way that day so I was
like okay and I understand George
sometimes does your telephone interviews
so can he step yeah yeah that's really
good to do it problem was I'm saying it
in one but I'm shaking I'm fight my
words aren't coming out but they could
see I was kind of on the ball and you
all just kept hammering me I remember
this man swimsuit mattis this now
going I do not want to do the commute I
do I've recently done a worser commute
so now you're not gonna do it
I've seen people how long as the
community is or may I'd be I'd be I'd be
worried about that
really yeah definitely all right I've
been doing like a similar commute prior
I've come in to finish it and then get
the truth yeah he's hammering me you're
having me I remember leaving like I
don't think I'm gonna get the job cuz
the commune and then they gave me a
trial day it was full-on oh my god the
job at this point I sell the job and
then I joined and I remember going in
like breaking it because he's got
Georgia yeah time and then literally
from day one I fell in love it no
looking back
just mad and I were to jam for a year
and a half just slightly over it was
like a few things business changes Nick
left and that was a big thing for me you
and will will go into that so basically
it's fine so it may that's a that is a
very interesting story I love the fact
how many obviously familiar names there
and they're now considered in your
recent role so I guess see it just to
frame not gonna see you spend year and a
half at Jam yeah and then after that you
now work in a role he do now which is
Hamilton Barnes so I went so when I left
jam the Eliza politics I left there and
then I joined comedy called console
bonus ok great company real eye-opener
for me that there was people were doing
the market that I was recruiting for and
I was like I am I didn't do a deal for
my first year but anyway I'm gonna talk
about that I started doing ok and then
and then I left
yeah I do you have much choice in the
matter Liam will not be there anymore
doing console honors and they're an
amazing business fairly recently sold to
an American company they're really cool
comedy bus or a few people there is
Michael Cox he is guy Ryan happens okay
right now it's Chronicle to signify a
billion like oh yeah I've seen that come
across them recently
yeah it's immature yeah but like Ryan
and other guys shortage Schwartz they
were bidding not obscene figures and
there was like not one or two people
like five six seven people doing those
kind of figures yeah I didn't do that
well yeah I see the problem was I joined
I fought I was really good at
recruitment hmm and I don't ever build
like 180 chaos and
and better than mine 24 Kenya 1 Lee yeah
well but you bill to zero and so yeah
yeah Oh may you built zero so it's zero
in 12 months and then I was there for
two and obviously no one on our theists
and then the next year and I 180 K I
didn't go single deal we're gonna talk
about and in the problem was right so I
walked out one day and I was about four
months in to consult yeah it's gone okay
he was quite hard for me so I wasn't as
good as what I pitched myself Internet
so there was a high bar and they were
really very short Billis so I think the
problem was from day one I'd set myself
artists come out on their walk down into
the reception and Nick and Georgia
standing there in the same building you
guys doing here I knew they were setting
up and what bonds at this point they're
all we've got an office on the second
floor oh [ __ ]
because I knew I was gonna be joining
them eventually one yeah have you really
got along them yeah and I really liked
working for the guys I thought yeah when
it seems they set up yeah so in the next
few months I'm like I don't want to go
there I need to finish it I need to like
you know I don't wanna be a failure here
kind of thing yeah and then they
proposed the opportunity to work then
I'll eat you had him on a scene straight
away and then for the first six months
are how about Barnes on cross all the
guys in the lift
oh but I used to think all the core they
must hate me but in reality I pre don't
give a [ __ ] but genuinely may be
dreading to go in the office you've been
on absolute journey and then and then so
when you join hands and bonds and you
obviously been there for and you build
more than zero just about that is that
is super interesting so let's let's
backtrack a bit yep
so I definitely want to talk about the
jam experience like just one or two
things run that and then we can dive
into like Hamilton Barnes and these
things right yeah so guess jam or cream
and then like what how did you not bill
in that for those first twelve months
like how did that happen like you must
have obviously come close quite a few
times like what went on in those first
twelve months and then how the hell did
you get through that so initially I
didn't really
you said you loved recruitment didn't
know yeah I just and you still loved it
the first couple of days like I work a
job for George and I'd get accounting on
every counter it's going yeah he's the
one he's I come in the office every day
I get in the office for like seven half
seven yeah I'd leave the office at 8
p.m. every day really and I just didn't
feel like I wasn't necessarily doing
anything wrong for me since it's gonna
happen and if I look back then what I
did then I don't even know how I ever
did do deals so I'm very much
disoriented oh I'm sure we'll talk about
now yeah but George is like very
processed yeah yeah just the freefall I
don't actually know how we ever did do
deals or placements but yeah then I
think I was really bought into Nick I
mean crazy so I think I always wanted to
do well by him I knew that he vouched me
a few times you really put so I guess in
those 12 months you really put in the
work effort yeah anything that unnoticed
even though you weren't oh god I didn't
come in the office and be like more
senior guys we're doing better me no
just feel I thought bath you did I don't
know how it did anyone point out James
you're doing this really wrong or
whatever like the prom was an issue so
we used to ownership with candidates
okay and uh ownership of Canada yes a
lot if George had a job I'd work the job
for George and it sends candidates to
never really know a job when it's not
your job yeah yeah they're always gonna
have a competitive edge I mean towards
were competing he wouldn't of got
anything for it if I had placed his jobs
so I'm really going out getting jobs and
then if I placed it he would lose the
for me naturally he used to place all of
them but I saw I was just busy idiot is
running around a headless chicken all
the time doing like free hours down the
foeman nothing guy real no real
substance vinyl and then Nick sat down
with memes are you let's start doing BD
taught me how to do BD and then was I
started to pick up a few clients here
and there but it was I was always
picking up clients in the ISP space so
it was this in the first four months
after yeah like I'd say like nine to ten
months yeah yeah my first placement was
a split we always wanted George's
clients he's guy called Yusuf Ali yeah
if you're listening Yusuf let ya showers
he Yusef I'm a guy the car station
buzzing oh i shaking trying to close it
one wife got pitching my head and why
I'm finally gonna do it
he was like yeah I'm gonna take the job
well I didn't have to say anything
really really easy place scripta my arm
and yeah then that wasn't even in that
in the patch but yeah it's always like
the 9 to 10 months period that's when I
started doing my own stuff yeah picked
up sky sure as a customer first deal at
sky he starts build confidence yeah and
then it'll got you but what got you
through that because so many people to
quit like it took me a lot super
successful genuinely would like how why
would you delete a someone makes for
example there'll be a holiday incentive
but i'm build at all I'll tell my mating
that in Vegas I'm gonna here but I
genuinely believe really like crazy
finger Bally I didn't this in my head I
was gonna drive an Audi r8 I don't even
drive now but I just had this weird
obscene like just uncalled for
confidence I was gonna be super
successful
I just I don't know what it was and then
I went outside to get a bit of success I
was still a bit of a pansy on the phone
because I did so much like time of not
doing what you just did
yes you've been back yourself yeah yeah
I remember I was in the front walking oh
yes manly I remember those there and the
guy was like um yeah we might offer him
like done really well did it spoke
really hard of him but model for him
I'll let you know okay no worries yeah
he said what say that's a hard case of
why we don't want to offer him that I
said a few things and the guys goes yeah
ok yeah what would offer it why George
is annoying I think I judges a psychic
telling me a stuff but he's me and him
are very different different approach
everyone has their own branch and
nothing back then I used to think he's
approached in hindsight
just a little tweak here and there just
change my feeling that some I had mine I
had my own I think that is something
that you really get better at it's
actually like backing yourself asking
the right questions listening and
pushing it back yeah and not being a
yes-man I think I remember my director
tell me that like you you can't be a
yes-man like a natural proper
recruitment consultant isn't a yes-man
yeah I mean and when you change people
we have clients yeah
they respect you a lot more but they
also saw that I appreciate it because if
you're willing to kind of challenge him
then you're not just a yes-man it's
important to than just go you know what
so then the last thing on Jam then
because there'll be a lot of people
listening that might be rotten I'm
hopefully I'm built for that twelve
months but like um there will be people
listening that will be struggling will
be going for a difficult patch and some
of them build and their desk these
things like what was that any looking
back was there anything in particular
that changed things like what George
said well actually he stopped saying yes
and actually pushed back and this is why
it's a lot what what was the only key
things that changed yeah I would say
probably yeah believing believing in
myself would kept me at it so if you're
doing the role not make sure you like
you've got to believe in yourself and
believing your ability there's a reason
why you stepped into the role initially
so you keeper that even yourself yeah as
soon as you don't as soon as you don't
back yourself and actually believe that
you are you should be speaking some
person you should be speaking to that
client or whatever then light you've
lost yeah exactly and just like building
on that a hundred so much believe in
your ability like I said all the time
the office the guys finally finding out
if I've a good Dave business development
I'm just I [ __ ] love this job
laughter me I love this job but who says
well it's not a joke salvia if you don't
enjoy it and I think that's good advice
like I actually like yeah like if you
are if you had some success or like it's
been really difficult and you like you
know what even when I have success I'm
not enjoying it as much yeah be honest
with yourself yeah definitely I think is
well that sounding point for me is just
not to be a yes-man 100 away for me is
just to be consultative you know
challenge people don't be afraid to
ignite that your voice be heard a little
bit as well whether that's internally
that's just genuinely in life generally
in lottery well I think from a
recruitment perspective yeah I just up
in the earth man just so many yes man
believing yourself and just just enjoy
it I think it's um it's hard because
it's a very unforgiving job if you're
not doing well yeah there's a lot of
emotion involved in it and there's a lot
of pressure depend on the business you
work for so it's hard to stick out but
you really do want to do it it's a crew
really passionate about like yourself
like you stuck out
years until a year and two sites of
rewards and just stick and if you
believe me there generally is there
generally is like the end of the tunnel
like yeah yeah okay man let's let's dive
into Hamilton Barnes end but well
actually just quickly yeah like how so
you know when obviously you as
surrounded by all these like big pillars
and stuff right so he built 180k and
this place obviously by that point you
wasn't the yes money was able to sell
yourself so you'll see oversold yourself
yeah on top on as a listen I've build
about to expanded so yeah so how cuz I
can imagine
I never went through this but I
definitely fell it in so I was in Austin
agency like eight people and like even
though like the two people that sat next
to me who the top pillars I did just
light and naturally feel a bit like
intimidated by them at the start by and
this Ally
I can imagine going into an environment
where one like you went through that
whole journey of like no I haven't
success having success I'm sure she had
more confidence you'd bet yourself more
Dingaan environment where like people
bill in like 500k more like [ __ ] like
how did you do it like you know I mean
that must have been cuz I'm sure a lot
of people listening may actually go
through that because like how but how
obviously left but like what how did how
was that like that must been difficult I
think the fingers would just kind of
take it back a step because George had
left him Jam oh yeah I stepped up and I
was like mental for you yeah I was like
a senior person so I thought I was like
top dog yeah top dog a jam for the team
last in and I was like 21 or 22 that's
not managing a few people or leading a
few people majors loser so yeah when I
turned up I was like it's a wake-up call
show away is I fooled the millions iPads
really yeah but I think as well I I kind
of I really enjoyed it I didn't want to
be around people that like average
bidders I wanted to be in a business
like I come in and I genuinely for get
inspired and as well console ways a bit
it's very like if you're like mid-20 our
code going up part in its perfect yeah
and but they make you feel really
welcome like it's come a long way I
think now but back then like that's how
you love part in his stuff and but
that's what positive I was 22 so yeah 21
22 so I was awesome for me
so I'd come into the business
you know I've fought I was the best the
area around I thought I was very niche
in the industry I did and they just done
double mission what I did really not a
half million pound a year
so I said mind-boggling but I just I
kind of embrace it I enjoyed it but they
also made you feel very well I found
life I thought I thought they wouldn't
have that first night out you're going
out like it's quite bearings before I
even started I went to the Christmas do
is when I started in my when I started
property in January there's pictures of
me like they put all my desk idiot
before you even started yes he knows
I've know and they're not once that you
forget are they really good guys that
really good banter there yeah but like
even like this summer taught by so a few
chapters in mysterious it out so Nick
Miller down quarks and Andy Mannion they
like they're like top top bit like
serious yeah and they would pull me to
one side and sit down on me like in on
it's not even really no dressing them
fell off the reason I was in the reason
I was intrigued was that sure I thought
using telling the opposite so I
absolutely love the fact that yeah in
there that was actually the case that's
really in China so they had a humility
right yeah like thanks like yeah it
agree he's so much like he was a nut
sounds good
I assume he's similar now he's a
director now but he's a mental are
people in the phone people would be like
cracking up cuz I he was just like sick
on the phone yeah and then he'd just
grabbed me off him I'll heard you'd like
this called you need some help and you
just help me I'm really you do get that
a jump he didn't get that when there was
Hoffman inbound videos because it wasn't
thank you yeah because you're thinking
from your perspective like short like
why would you give me his time yeah yeah
Mike oh I just straight away like the
pressures on that when you coming in
that role I feel the pressure
straightaway I mean that's a big thing
going to people that are like senior
being themselves a senior that's one
thing to just consider when you're
moving like if you're you're gonna make
a rod for your own back if you can't
over so yourself to the green yeah and
also as well just be aware of the kind
of pressures of a senior person that
comes in probably didn't think I was on
the pressure console probably didn't
think that but from day one I I'm
invited 45k in a month I did 60 cave the
year it took me about five months to do
that yeah I did it in two months and
then
oh yeah funny doing it there but I think
that's good because you didn't set me up
when I got to hammer bond here 1 I build
ex Manos yeah well I think obviously
would mate or see what it made you
realize is actually what hangman at law
I thought this was like yeah to be fair
I think may that that's really cool and
I guess again like you don't know what's
possible until it's long around you they
online I think if the topper lives in my
old place it was more like he had like
300 400 K maybe look a bit less and it
faster then go to London at that point
and then there's like six understand
okay a million pound Belize blood like
[ __ ] and then it's like all of a sudden
that's real and it's achievable
yeah yeah so quick when then before we
go into Hammonds and bonds and your
journey Darrow is like so quick quick
insight and Tori what do you send in
common habits in these people they were
like oh my god they're like a big big
big bill it's good laughs one if I was
okay is no joke one of the things I know
issues and there were big accounts being
account yeah that's a big household
names everyone had at least one
household name that's interesting that
like they really like made a lot of cash
out yeah I wonder that one or two the
guys had like just one big account and
that's what they did really like
everything cost by that account that in
great some positive things into me yeah
I think it's interesting like if you
were to look at say one of the guys
cocktail mentioned earlier he's a
workhorse I he'll come in and like from
nine to six when they leave
he will not be off the phone it'll be
holding the phone the whole day but then
like any Mannion when the other chaps
he's very like quite reserved I don't
know if he sees everyone has everyone
has their own matter than that that's
what I always fall out you need to smash
the phones and like when I was at Jam I
think I definitely know like now yeah I
learned a lot from being there cuz you
sort of contrast yeah yeah and they'll
be competing for the top spot within
like one of them is hammering the phone
all the time and man you probably would
be on the phone which is not that kind
of persona you might be no I don't know
no no that's really interesting
okay so then finally got reunited what I
was you the so lady who Natasha and
Tonio they were working parts on two
days a week
Antonio was doing his uni placement
there yeah so always the first permanent
employee
really
Antonio's starting like two weeks after
I mean how many of you there nah it's 20
we did a high 13 people in the last year
yeah mate last mats you've been on an
interesting journey that though yeah
yeah it's gone even while the lasts say
nine months just okay well let's talk a
bit this sort of uncover a bit that
journey so like by this point obviously
went through that really difficult first
12 months then obviously gained more
confidence back to yourself learnt a lot
there build more when insistent
environment was a lot oh my god what
like oh my god there's a whole nother
level to this game obviously then not
always he had the opportunity with
George and Nick seeing him in the left
arm
this is weird like so you and then talk
a bit about how are the first twelve you
like just hit the ground running
straight away or like what what went on
when you join Hamilton buttons so there
was a few things like when I joined I
picked up from console so they do secure
deals so 15 cent to the candidate 50
cent for the client so I bought that
intro way something I won't have any
clients at least be a good idea he's
something the business still does now
yeah so the first literally the first
say
April's the first four months was out
end of the financial year yeah so as
long as I do like a deal or month I'd be
happy with a cover my see I'm focused on
building something bigger you know so
I'd get home I'd work Monday's Friday
8:00 till seven or my stuff then I'd get
home to my laptop home which resource
all of George's jobs it's really tender
mouth shorts cuz I was thinking like I
need to do deals I don't have any
clients I don't want Nick and George
because I knew they took a big they took
a big pun on hiring me this yeah do you
do want to take that for granted no
exactly you know I just didn't wanna let
them down so I just made sure our
results like every night get home so the
first few months um I did a placement my
first month yeah and it was literally
like the last day of January January and
I was in the office I wasn't a scientist
guy I feel like you know I trying to
close it he accepted we went to the
whence the pod went out a bit and that's
he nights to be fair but it was um and
then I was just set up I'm just gonna
keep doing spiritual George and then I
start building up my own business yeah
and this went on for even for the first
year and a half of me really resources
jobs are if I didn't have enough for
nagy go home horsies
so it was you so at this point he was
building that you're a niche business
yeah
so I've done the Internet service what I
saw before so I was bought in so George
does more enterprise which is like
vendor Bree says okay and like big
end-users I do in Sarasota Florida so
that no one was doing this so at the
time it was like Nick George you know
what you mean yeah and the other guys
but then you have clients but this point
though obviously but could you not speak
to them not really no because when other
words a console we I did Europe I've
never I did Europe for the year prior I
did the UK okay so I have few
relationships there wasn't I was never
like even with anyone yeah officer then
come in and refresh it that's
interesting well let's definitely talk a
bit about that then because probably one
of the most common questions I get to
ask people is about building a new desk
or business development these things
that's gonna be key to you having
success and that new division right so
let's talk a bit about that so you've
learnt a console that okay if I can get
a big account then that that could
hopefully set me up to also you be in a
really good place yeah and then yeah and
then you're also building out a new team
within this business so how did you go
about that then alright so right down to
basics and mapping out there's
directories for the industry yeah and
then mixed bag so mix between LinkedIn
direct messaging managers candidates
them you open them but then also as well
doing when you said that sorry spewed
engage of candidates and say are you
looking for a job so I tried team as
management roles so I pulled in network
manager role yeah that's a BD
opportunity for me
yeah so I'd get the job honors okay that
make sense or sit but in every campaign
I work with potential clients yeah I
tried to do that like as much as
possible but within like three months of
being there I picked up a couple of big
bigger clients and I go how do you do
that just through what you just said
through that and talked about shots
really like one of them I knew that the
company looked for language speakers I
had a really good lunch I really good
German speakers it's just speken in
Canada yeah yeah so you're really
targeted you know doing the basics I
lead on
needs an indeed or then like general eat
and then one thing I like especially
over the last two years I'm really anal
with by just follow up and I think
following ski and any of sounds right so
like oh my god good at that that was big
that was big for me as well and I
realize that like when you really get a
hold of your follow-ups like yeah that
really helps yeah definitely
I feel like I already time management
book like two years ago and I first when
it turned for me but even back then I
used to do a lot booking I want another
thing I learned from console they
booking calls all the time I never you
stay up yeah but no I'd have a call with
a client and I'd follow up booking the
call follow-up and then that way as well
I always look at as a minimum input
maximum output yeah what's the point of
dining someone twenty-five times when
you can say I'll call you at four and
calling back yes I went from like I
don't know I make ten contacts five of
them would be callbacks and then if I do
that every week for months I've been
gone my BD calls mapped out for me yeah
okay so when you say follow-up do you
mean as in like if you didn't get a hold
of them then okay you're following our
pause as in like when you spoken to them
like okay let's speak again and a
monster time or whatever yeah so again
it comes back to what we spoke about
yeah so I just not be a yes-man to when
someone says I'm not looking now just
asking the questions okay so when are
you looking you know what you know and
then you okay so if you was going to do
is I'll put a calling a diary for six
weeks from now if you're not looking now
let's have a general catch up if you're
not looking we'll just push you into
yeah you'd be surprised how many people
just go okay noise and then you just
also you get a snowboarding yeah that's
that's pretty good advice I think that
some nice thought I do did for the last
sort of twelve months and that helped me
a lot actually because again like your
typical your typical recruit isn't gonna
be doing that and then it's about okay
well actually when you do call in six
weeks again you it's about be in front
of mind isn't it so hopefully by the
time maybe they are looking which is six
twelve months or whatever and not twelve
months twelve weeks whatever then they
should hopefully be thinking that James
rather than the guy that caught them on
the lucky
yeah or whatever do not I mean and you
always gather like oh you know she's had
this role for two weeks go sorry and
you've just missed out when you've just
called someone whereas if you've got
corporate simulant
you'd like to think they're gonna so I
do a lot of that and I think is
the biggest thing of that and missus I
go is about the same but actually follow
up yes like truth I used to cause I'm so
busy then I'd miss a couple of the calls
and then next meet you're trying to call
them back and you so again initial
reputation in that like people oh you
know I even though that conversation
might be in like 60 seconds yeah like
James call me when he's gonna say he's
gonna call me it's like yeah the
standard that you essentially if James
tells me is gonna work on this job or
whatever then like you know I mean it's
saying that standards just atrocity like
yeah you just set the time yeah if you
have 10 minutes 15 minutes half an hour
like every time you call him okay me how
so then so I came in and then what went
on after that year and a half then so by
that year and a half did you have sort
of a solid banker clients yeah so I did
like in the May I think it was no soon
that and the March I did like 32 grand
month I was like a pixel right that was
a few clients one particular client was
one one big deal on there couple of
small things but I was still doing
splits all the way through and I looked
at this before today actually each tower
interest yeah and it was like even in my
second year I was doing noise of splits
looking if I've got enough to keep you
busy not get home on HP so when you say
split would you mean cuz I'm I I that
actually yeah we did house split so
basically a split would be if it was
Mike Ryan and my colleague got me the
candidate I'd be 5050 we used to do that
actually so George had loads of jobs I
didn't have as many so I'd go home look
II his job was Ben hasn't got anyone on
final interview and then I would go
through LinkedIn and just Hamelin
LinkedIn or do a mouse on the database
or jobs so I was just you know sitting
on the sofa watching TV just hammering
now and then during the day I was pick
up my own clients so will you send the
splits have been like yeah that's really
interesting
okay so again not the guess if you
haven't got like this splits opportunity
in your office right now like be
speaking to manager and like try that
out or whatever yeah yeah again everyone
wins right and yeah like I think again
obviously its competitive but if you've
got three or four people actually vested
and actually there's an opportunity for
me to make money here then that's a good
thing I think
anything and it just promotes erm and
it's one of the big things I think how
old bonds have done really well
everybody gets on there's a lot of inter
team dealings placements you know people
actually really want to do well by one
love you can do by doing this bit of the
night oh yeah a fair thing come back off
forgot about that actually that I did
quite a few of those and that yeah that
you look totally right actually this is
is actually really I felt it does impact
the environment than that quite promotes
collaboration rather than like so then
so year and a half in and then what yes
what's going on sort of three years off
a lot free what three years three years
pretty much after that yes when did you
start getting a team underneath you and
stuff so it's probably about this time
two years ago okay I'd like yeah I don't
all right they've got 120-180 some of
that and then next year off he was like
240 issues it was in between the 182
four years yeah so I hired there was a I
mentioned earlier she started just
resourcing yeah on myself all not
resourcing but working a little bit more
money and doing her own stuff as well
and then we hide another trap as well
but like I really tell you very serious
um I don't think I realize the
opportunity to add so I just did
when you say you didn't take it very
serious with them in so I'd be like I'd
always be very passionate and very like
I'd have loads of good idea to be
fruitful of ideas and always why let's
do this this do that and all those are
the best intentions but then I was just
too immature used to go a lot not used
to no used to drive the team as well as
you go it should be yeah yeah and what I
could have its in that kind of yeah
fizzled out an improperly properly this
time last year maybe a little bit
earlier on January last year 18 Billy
Joe my team and then from there really
it's been we're now it's a team of six
okay
let's talk a bit about that then like
what changed them do not mean right so
what what change for James Dean yeah I
can tell you the exact exact month it
was so I had I read about RIT once like
you know that 80/20 prior principal
yeah 80% of your clients give you 20%
your clients give you B's oh yeah then
also as well I give you 80% yack yeah
this one client that used to give me
real hard time yeah it's just waste so
much time reserves and their jobs doing
this dinner and they backdoored me on
quite a senior guy yeah so Knicks if we
can either you know that we do a few
places well we do a lot of them or we
could obviously probably book him and
get the fee yeah it was black and white
I just took him off us yeah even the
candidate made it as well so I I push
for it was like no I don't know work
them anymore because I've read this book
and it says they give me loads of back
so and then in this month I just had a
good month other stuff surprised that my
best month was our 30k month because
back in the May March show when I first
died and I'd like a 47 and a half grand
month Oh what am i doing so I stopped so
I literally stopped going out in a week
stop pissing around and just started
really hammering it really I'm just
started taking a lot more serious just
like you know just little things I just
get your day pan done get my day's plans
so I just immerse my subjects so I guess
it was actually like what the
realization was actually I'm actually
really taking this opportunity for
granted yeah yeah it was big wake-up
calls every time I'd sit down with Nick
oh yeah this month I'm gonna build this
and he really said that last month
what's different this month I mean this
one and I felt like yeah so like I said
that you then focusing not going out
drinking his March that had the ruined
Pat that nor was it just that moment of
actually actually we've just got ridden
over actually we were doing okay but
there's a rotten apple and I was then
free to them focus on other things were
many fruitful was it no I think the
definitely help the pinning off that
particular customer I mentioned you know
were what I thought let's go up in it
yeah but no she's a wake-up call that I
could actually do the job and do quite
well hmm even I did my promotional
meeting a year on I showed that pitch
then they can George that was a moment I
knew I could do it so yards yeah still
would go out and not knowing near as
much really like rain things in just I
focusing that side yeah immersing myself
in personal development yeah so I just
doubling down on everything that I've
read and dropping down on James Dean
exactly that's really dude like that
okay and then some it seems like
your your billions in your performance
she's gone in like one direction like up
really cool yeah so then so then so from
and then so you couldn't now got team of
six you had that realization moment and
then was that when you really start
building the team but underneath you and
so that's it yeah
so Billy really joined the seem like
genuine for every time and then he
resource for me pretty much solely and
then September October he kind of flew
the nest and slide doing his own stuff
I'm consoling yeah
really not to three months he's now yeah
he was then sort of fully fledged
console when I see Tom Soehn become a
senior uh-huh so he's done really well I
feel I hide some really good guys
there's a lot of successful last year I
could really vouch for them not they've
you know they work their ass off for me
yeah so you know jack joined in October
he was like my protege so I did like
training with you know Andy says oh yeah
I did that training the strategic coach
yeah I'll come back in all right Jack
yes he loved it use all what are you
learning training today haha I know that
yeah it went from there you know me
higher the Chapel Charlie he was doing
database and quick one sorry to buy him
but one and what so you've had some many
successful hires I'm sure you've had
some not so successful hires what what
things have you again are there any key
and indicators that you've noticed then
then then that being really successful
you know I mean that's a common question
I ever II was different but like what
key indicators do you now look for
knowing that you've now got these guys
that are really good for you done really
good for you yeah it's a good question
quiet giveaway for anyone else use of me
well I see the best in everyone so I'll
come out I always say to Nick on each
sleep on it because I'll come out on a
lot good so I think for me like the main
thing for me is if like and this is
Hamilton bars are businesses like
different probably but I just like
people that as a business we to look for
people that just settle you know just
can get on with everyone so likability
yeah you can get on with someone in the
interview and but then also as well
someone that's shown a bit of life
experience
yeah which is ironic because I didn't
have we mean by life experience like
like someone's got a degree great but
it's more about they went to university
well they did at university yeah I think
if someone's lived away from home
I traveled yeah just a bit of a story to
go and for me it's basic massively on
conversation yeah so if I find that I'm
having to ask those questions base were
really difficult for you to lie at have
a conversation yeah no I'm not having to
program notes or if if I realize I'm
talking those and I like them because of
okay oh I couldn't pin it down yeah yeah
yeah okay so then sorry I'll buy in
there but and then worse then you record
a couple of good guys you were saying
when you should shot was it Charlie and
yeah yeah yeah so then the news carried
on building makes me yes and we hired
another chap James he joined as well
girls that make yes we use writer X we
use a couple of different ones yeah it's
the thing is the art they are any here i
so i did a meeting with one of our
biggest clients are big 4200 company and
they like our you know talking about
diversity in the workplace it's a
business effort last night yeah just
come down to james like exactly and i
think it's one of them know we can only
interview the candidates are put in
front of us yeah okay so carried on
building this team and then the all of
these guys are resourceful you know I
know so
sir Billy is now senior okay yeah me and
him are kind of the the farmers we bring
the clients and then the chaps are
there's Jack and Charlie are starting to
do their own bit as well okay but it's
like we've got some quite big accounts
and and for a small business at the
moment like you know for example today
this week for example meeting like six
different clients yeah it's six
different businesses over five days from
12 different meetings we just got jobs
Cara is yes so the guys are almost a bit
like there's no point me doing because
you've
and there's a great opportunity the
split that's really interested in so few
things around that is firstly so just so
I'm though for this like Dee said right
now do you have no contact with
candidates now like you but totally
apart from that good question
no I know no so we still get involved
more senior stuff I'll probably do we
also it's all about like like the return
on investment if we got you know 50
grand a year salary role and it took me
two to three days to resource it my time
would be better off spending elsewhere
wouldn't really good way to think about
it yeah if it was a senior appointment
or like a direct or a major right it
might be slightly different because
again like because you you want to make
sure that yeah like the people that
you're putting in the up to up to the
mark yeah but a lot of stuff we do so
like just say for example Jack
Constantine are these five candidates
quite often pretty not so much now you
know so he's doing now but that quite
often more so the beginning means the
shortest slightly or as well like if as
soon as anyone's in play I try to touch
base people like to hear and I'm a voice
and in placements I'll meet all the
cameras we play sighs really yes we try
and even if it's coffee or trunk out for
lunch I try to a lot simply do the
Midlands in the north so they don't
don't even mean yeah we do like annual
meals where we take the teams out really
but if someone's in London yeah what
what just one thing about that just I'll
completely rusty because it might be a
few people listen that could get a bit
of value out of this is like so what I'm
sure you got better and that process in
terms of light Jeff finds a candidate
and then you decide if it hits the mark
or not yeah but how how have you
streamline that process to get on you
know I mean because I'm sure there was
some learnings and challenges and
failures of that like what is every just
got a really clean process now where
it's like okay I need to only speak to
me when you've done this with these
candidates so one feel I found
especially previously when I used to
manage management to lose some yeah but
I used to just sit there and like do
this do this do that do this and I'd be
tending what's do all day it's when they
get a can now install I'm doing I talk
to them and it was very
counterproductive and then after the
training that Andy gun and one of the
big things he said about it was like
just kind of front-loading your time so
I'll sit down with the guys I'll do
you know half an hour maybe an hour in
the morning I have our three hour slot
so I have nine to ten eleven to twelve
and then five to six which is free the
guys can book in whatever they wanted
I'm gonna sit down could be half an hour
there's always there's always free hours
that your team can sit down on James
yeah they're managers just so often it's
like five minutes scrum will do but then
if they're getting a new role or they
need to reek wallah fire list or when
somebody new starts first no one do is
look at this guy I'll tell you about
yeah so we just sit down in points
because the fingers with that as well
they get more on the volume attention
yeah if they're doing it if they grab me
on the hop and I'm in the middle at this
I I don't get the attention you want so
we just do it in small chunks and then
that way it's in between in between
stages they can ask each other questions
and they can interact between themselves
but they don't need to keep pestering me
about it because they know you're gonna
get that fifteen minutes later yeah
that's that's that's really good advice
okay and then I guess what what I wanted
to sort of dive into a bit is so yeah as
I said like I mean through everything
that you're speaking about to to ensure
that your Billings keep going up like
that must have been really challenging
my in terms of there's more people
involved and all that yeah
and so yeah let's just let it run though
like what sort of like what would what
did you finish on that
[Laughter]
okay so basically what all owner to us
why ask that was clearly it's gone in
one direction I think again thinking of
the questions that I get asked is I've
had quite a few times he shim on the I'm
at the sort of hundred fifty 180 came up
on a break the two hundred came up
brother blow that so like what and I'm
sure there might be a few things in this
but like how have you continued for it
to keep going in that direction and
light do you not I mean has there been
some key things or just like well I
should take me to the next level
whatever one of them clearly being that
that account that you ended up stopped
working yeah yeah yeah little bit like
what yeah what sort of helps you get you
know I mean what were the key things
that helped you get to that point so I
one of the big things I did was equally
that I'd bend off that account a lot of
the work I was doing places yeah one one
or two customers so I just double down
on that and I just really really rinse
that and one of the beacons I'm pretty
good at he expanded than the current
one of the big things I'm good at is
getting the most out of an account so
I'll see offering five of the top ten
customers of Hammer bonds with my
customers the top two of my customers so
it's like I don't just like like one
thing that I know a lot of recruiters
like that like the chase and they like
getting like yeah I was at an eight
month on - next on there as I would like
do the first placement that's where the
fun begins you know who else can I help
you with who I was can I can support you
if I said that wasn't me my next
question before you move on like was
like to go to advice on expanding
accounts all right so you put place
you've Bob Bob yeah has been looking
desperately for six months you doing a
really good job take him out for beers
or gaff dinner for lunch and you say -
but I really want to grab the team it's
one of the things that I've done when
you are involved all my customers in my
journey really so even like with the top
pillar thing with George love I involve
them in it so I would say to him that
I'm really keen to hire more people in
the business I really want to grow but
one thing clients don't want to do they
don't want to tell you about their peers
because you're gonna stop working their
stuff ya know when you to not prioritize
their stuff she just say to him no for
my growth for my progression I'm growing
out the team I be really keen to start
supporting X business in other areas who
looks after this and then I'll tell you
the name do you mind if I say you mean
you know each other yeah yeah of course
guy and then you just go of it don't ask
for the mission but just like assume
that you don't say oh yeah can you ask
this person I think that's a big thing
a that's really I'm really good inside
that and I think that ties into some in
the hoenn and pick up on your point of
view on but it's like you're you're
you're just being really personal there
aren't you know she's yes yeah I'll
really like that be gone through yeah I
guess that was one of the other things I
was gonna say young I used to be like
you know the whole we use the term stick
it on someone nasty oh yeah gotta stick
it on him so I used to get like from
when I went from being a yes man I was
just Aggie so I've come on I mess around
I want to fight that's what a tear on
again mess me around I just get really
angry of them and then I actually learn
how to be a bit more assertive and just
being a bit more or consultive and I
think that made a massive difference
I like being willing to kind of lose the
deal and being willing to miss out on a
placement for the long term getting a
nice I was a massive thing so rather
than like just you know get an Aggie of
everyone trying to push
take the let's take the long time once
on it because actually this account
could become a go from a 50 count count
to 150 pair can't we get it now we're
like a customer so I've already got for
final interview so do you really for me
you put v in right now you know don't
worry
and they're like what you say down my
throat whoever should be a bit more
human with it I think there's a massive
[ __ ] em it may that's dust a some really
good advice me everyone me I mean
everyone I do so many meetings I'd say I
spend probably an average lot half of
that week in the office come in me and
other people in that business yeah yeah
some meet clients like anytime I'll
speech someone if one of the clients
that I work with about 20 minute walk so
my first point of contact well nice to
meet you didn't release were actually
let me pop down I'll grab a quick coffee
oh okay what song he do tomorrow and
then go meet him like I do it so much
and that's one of the big things I think
anyway why I've grown out accounts as
much as I have like with the business
and that sign nicks drove down really on
to me he meets everyone as well that's
really interesting and then I guess
quick on than that just thinking about
my own experience and I think I think
very people were very easy to go like
like let's grab a coffee right but I
think what's your free I'm sure you've
experienced this then actually well
these people will no doubt that I'm Paul
right yeah so like what's your view on
that likes you like should you just be
like look I'll come I'll come to you or
like to not I mean because that's
straight away if it's like a new sort of
relationship that's why I think people
don't quite quickly don't they like
let's grab a coffee but it's like yeah
well actually like how can you help me
what's gonna what's going to be the
benefit of us spending time together was
always going straight shot like near the
particular phone I mentioned yeah cuz I
say that they like I know the area yeah
fair enough and but I think the main
thing and this is again like another
side step actually it's just like you
talked about their process especially
when you're working recruitment HR
termination I just say to him like let's
meet up
let's grab 15-20 minutes I won
understand your process I can tell you
the success success I've had within the
business let me understand how you want
it to work
that's everyone's grab 20 minutes and
then when you meet up then you're not
like being a pushy recruit actually
trying to understand how they want it to
work yeah that's really good actually so
actually the point of view that you're
taking the approach is
well actually I want to come and
basically listen to how you work yeah
I'm happy to work - how are you work
yeah and I'll see ya when you sat down
and we can build relationships and
obviously then you can start actually
maneuvering that process of benefits you
and everyone involved and it's not about
like completely kibosh in their process
no no but no but that's really rather a
lot of people have a lot of gripes and
negative - internal recruitment HR
whatever bad I think that's a really
good way to have the perspective when
it's actually let me come and listen and
understand your process and how you like
to work you know let's let's start from
there okay I trying to tell my guys
because like you said like although you
know the enemy over what's happening
enemy yeah one thing I've done really
good ice building relation really well
as building relationships with those
people yes
what was the hiring manager monograph
the five people they might hire one
person a year the internal recruiter is
gonna see everything you need to get
them on your side yeah yeah and there's
why I'm a big believer in like if you
can't speak to people you might as well
rather than like okay so big accounts
yeah expanding account yeah what else
has enabled you to sort of take your
building to the next level what was it
sticks out yeah a few things I would say
time management yeah like it's quite
funny we spoke about this the other day
yeah I'm terrible in a personal life
yeah you are a bit of a flake man yeah I
am I'm terrible but it's just like but
Monday to Friday you look at my calendar
honest got calls every 10 minutes like
it's not I'm pretty anal with stuff that
but then it's weird yeah second I step
by the office I don't know what yeah no
I think I think that's evident when you
said earlier that my time is better
spent elsewhere so I think now Monday to
Friday really value your time you know
you all you're thinking about actually
if I spend 15 minutes on this is that
going to mean that there's gonna be this
outcome that's actually worth my time so
you really really valuable value your
time which is key and I think is wrong
with that I used to work 12-hour days
and not do any placements so I don't go
back to doing that I'm like a huge
motivation not to be the case making it
work I'm wrong and running around I had
this chicken oh yeah calling people no
pick up and I think is well goals are
quite a big thing like this yeah like
more in settings huge doesn't mean
that's a hard job like you know - it's
very unforgiving not to do well in if
you have your goal just like I said
earlier like I was probably ambitious
within goals no I did have gone you had
something in his aim
yeah yeah like I'll open you admit now
like the beginning of this year counting
the finally a last couple of months I
found a little bit tough to you know
coming to work I was finally like days
harder yes
prior to hours I've got big George Lyon
I beat Georgia like Suze I got like the
first month in I'm like running around I
hit the chicken again a little bit like
lost my purpose yeah I found my purpose
can I know I'm doing I know my goals and
he just flipped so his head again back
to it like if you have if you haven't
because I really agree that I think if I
yeah I'm in recruitment it can be really
repetitive it obviously like you you can
go through parts of Islam a good light
I'm just doing the same thing and then
if you if you're able to take a step
back and go actually it's gonna help me
get to this outcome yeah then that's
really beneficial yeah I think for me as
well like now I've got the guys I enjoy
I was in a cell light of you really
enjoyed that now seen their success and
then growing and also you have an impact
in that and I knew before I did
especially like previously when I had
the other twos also mentioned earlier I
just like someone's always doing all I
really mind whereas now is like you know
this year if I didn't do nowhere near as
much right there but the team really
smashed I think I'd be happier he's a
weird one a lot Billy for example like
when I first I work of him me and him
would like mmm clashing a few things
here and there but I was I was very not
pushy and not micromanage yeah and then
like now he's like hopefully bats boys
first house stuff is I'm like a proud
father like line or does a placement his
first new client that's so cool I love
it this is weird never be a thing that's
wicked
and then so definitely what honest to
get your view on just because of the
things that we spoke about and stuff and
I know it's definitely important to both
of us like so you mentioned mindset
they're like two things one like when
did that become more important you know
I mean that how did you get there and
into yeah like how do you try it cuz
obviously clear now it's important in
southern impact in terms of you
continuously improve in what how do you
try and instill that in your people in
your team's you know I mean that's
definitely a difficult one but tough
question yeah the lights a limb firstly
like James Dean like I had my own
journey with a and it
definitely I mean that it's gonna help
me get through start my own business and
it helped me when I was at hawk so and
then recruitment like you know how is I
mean that you didn't build for 12 months
like there's going resilience and keep
going so like what how did why did you
start invest in Warren um as I saying
just before the lights went out really
annoying so yeah like when how did that
do not mean like why did you start
investing more in that like how did that
come about
was there any particular reason like the
whole development stuff yeah I was just
I think oh the big things are when I was
doing okay yeah or some people deem it
as well I was just like we die pissed
off all the time I was never really
happy of what I was doing
yeah I thought kind of because I had
always had this mad expectation I was
gonna just gonna smash you inside to get
to reality no I wasn't actually gonna be
a millionaire but I'm 25 yeah
so I I've always read but I used to read
because people told me I should and I'm
line that you should and I started
investing into that I started to like
relate to a lot of it so slightly
implementing I found out later based
like stoic ISM so yeah yeah so it's like
you know and this what I say every day
to the guys if they're pissed off about
academe oh he didn't turn into you look
there's things you can control and
there's things you can't control you
know I stopped worrying about the things
you can't pinch me that sounds so simple
but it's such again oh yeah I don't do
it no no but I used to sit there and I
blow out of a can like job have an inch
card to lose my shirt from a mouse
absolutely obvious I'll go for a strop
and I'd come back to me as they do not
like oh and they brew my whole day
we're in my week I mean this one guy he
was a 15 grand deal and uh 15 grand fee
and he drops out was Friday he drops out
he meant starting the Monday I just hear
like a ton of bricks sue me about a
month to get over it and then I think
it's roughly around about the same time
aside to reading stuff but just go in
selling that laughing but then I'm sorry
noise things about like you're in
control your own destiny and I read the
toy Robbins are waking Johnny the bangle
reading yeah I actually started but that
was one of the first few books I read a
nice Thai reading again yeah generally
no [ __ ] yeah mate honestly I think
that that's that's enough for me and I
think a lot of people get a lot of value
out that I spoke about before like for
me I think what what helped me early on
was the
because I've been this what went from my
own journey and I sort of by when I was
in recruitment I was sort of meditating
and I was very comfortable with like
being accountable but also I was very
aware that well I've got better at it
because it was difficult at first but
when you realize actually like yeah you
control the controllables right sound
advice but yeah if you can if you can
have that failure on Friday and actually
not let that affect you you yeah and
like you were still being productive and
doing the right things like that's gonna
give you an edge over your competitor
because there's gonna be very very very
high chance that they're gonna let that
ruin their day and the fuse work if I'm
like leading a group of guys you know
five these six people and I have a
candidate or client withdraw a job or do
something and I get stroppy and acting
like a bit of a teenager I can't manage
yeah just focus
forget about what you can't control not
forget but redouble down and what you
can control and I think and then I think
that ties into being accountable as well
it's like okay so I can't well I look at
parts of that I could control like what
did I miss
yeah what could I learn from that and
start asking those questions is really
sound advice enough yes love that mate
and then yeah the last thing then like
for me I'm thinking if I was grown a
team like I know it's important and you
know is like how do you drive light or
so you say that every day but like how
do you want instill that in your guys to
do like you know I mean I try to lead by
example
yeah you know try not to wear my
emotions on my sleeve yeah you know try
to just be calm and collected and then
like you know when they forest drop just
trying to relate back to inch but I look
like you know in your day and then just
try and snap them back to what we're
actually doing the task in hand
oh yeah the classy one aged frog it's
always at the brand Bob you spoken to
the cabinet you know but he's not gonna
go I'm not call him and then Charlie for
example he's quite funny story like very
very short version no he's all scores
not gonna go he's very relaxed choice
he's always I'm gonna go to interview oh
okay so yeah just hold me don't wanna
girls like if you said if he needs up no
no II just said you were gonna go so I
call that comment you find out why I
hate that when your manager guys cooling
back and see cooling about look I'm like
kind of guy where I feel like hammer
everyone but if I think there's a need
to yeah
the only time I probably ever get
annoyed is if someone you think it's the
most amazing opportunity and some wasn't
gonna go for with it my gin you know I
caught you doing know I include us
anyway Charlie called this candidate
back gets off the phone husband yeah
he's going I wonder what it goes I said
something to do this he was saying
trivial he went in you got the job he's
first place like see and it's good when
you have these examples in it makes a
lot easier because they denied otherwise
I'm always talking about my success
stories I did this I did that when you
actually can tell them to do something
they actually it works then yeah all
right
to two last things mate yeah we wrap up
it's gone quite quick enough
yeah these last things so last thing
because I think I mean you spoke quite a
lot about it but definitely there were
people listening that might be new to
management they might be in it they
might be thinking about these things
like obviously just straight to the
point like water this summer because you
mentioned earlier about those free hours
that you have is there anything else in
that management piece that people could
really benefit from if they're coming
and building and managing a team whilst
still bill English is extremely
difficult and you've managed to keep
your Billings and improve your Billings
but what yeah what other things around
the management piece that sort of worth
talking about you know a little plug for
Andy yeah I get I'd get involved with a
boy trainer so yeah that lead she
changed my entire approach just having a
bit of a manual to go to and having that
bar I'd say the main things use
front-load the time you spend with
people yeah so if you're gonna spend
time with him spend time don't do it
while you're on your phone yeah
something else Ask Don't Tell that's one
of the things that he teaches yeah so
when they ask for answers don't tell
them the answer they know the answer so
ask him so what do you get out of them
yes what would you do in this instance
what we've done previously and then try
and get it it's quite funny cuz now
Billy Billy I know you're gonna say I
don't know the answer just tell me on
your expert advice and as well just like
just allow people to take the risk in
like maybe not do it perfectly so I you
know just crack let them crack on and
maybe make mistakes yeah and then
longer-term they're gonna be a lot less
reliant and then the last thing I wanted
to
speak about it might be one more
question on Hoshi but obviously you like
if I look at sort of your LinkedIn and
stuff like you've got a huge Network
yeah and like I know we spoke about it
and I've tried to encourage me and stuff
but like sort of do more content online
and stuff like that yeah but what's your
hope you on that because obviously it
sounds like you went through
obviously smashing the phones then you
saw this other guy that was billion
loads it wasn't smashing the phones yeah
and then now it seems like you've sort
of got your own approach but obviously
like yeah what's been your journey on
that and like how has that evolved for
you from this off
great concept of yourself personal
branding stuff because I feel like you
still get that and yeah definitely I
think I used to believe in LinkedIn
because the whole passive carry anything
yeah I'm not saying I don't anymore but
I mean that was what I used to message
people because I'd always get candidates
that no one else had in the office
really thing else and that will use hit
LinkedIn hard yeah message everyone I've
got a lot of thirty thousand connections
maxed out and most and more relevant
there's a few irrelevant and how did you
grow that littered like to manually
connect some of these people yeah I use
a few toes yeah yeah mainly I was up to
about 25,000 before I even started using
that's always done yeah yeah I put up a
surge go home and add like max out how
many people work it out message them add
them and they come back to me I want to
add them and then are you messaging
these people going straight for the kill
straight up let's have a coffee you know
your skills that quite good for a role
on recruiting on yeah it'd be good to
connect if you're not looking then no
worries good scanning for the future and
then if they come back then when they
accept I'll send them a message would be
quite killer here like a standard
template blah yeah thanks for connecting
but it always be a role specific 10 so
okay so you'd always tell them about a
job straight out yeah pretty much quite
or on it cuz now I definitely wouldn't
do that that's mad that's what I'm in
and I think I love success outlaw why do
you I think I 50% of my billions from
LinkedIn first I was a massive advocate
that's fine I then now like I see me
talking having dunno near as much
content as I should but there's a few
weeks so I'll hit hard I was going from
holiday saw slowed down a bit but but
full of holiday yeah they're not two
videos a week yeah and the great thing
is I've got big connection so I'm get
like 25 25 min a lot of engagement and I
should
do something with like first fee first
placement which I directly say that was
from from my comment on the post yeah we
started chatting and there's a couple of
others got an interview so yeah he's a
big thing I feel like for me I'm very
much about like I said oh yeah minimum
maximum output yeah I [ __ ] reach out
to people in everything that's a deal on
the phone or those amount of meetings in
one day not being behind the camera
actually I never did and then the first
day I did it I walk to the office
looking around like everyone Blanca and
in a couple of days they are on life I
mean I'm really open with like the first
video I did it was like I was like so
stiff and I was grim yeah they talked
about five times to do it but yeah like
anything you just get better and you
build confidence and these things I
think just to add on what you said I
think if I watch your videos and my
perception and this is what I'm finding
as well with a lot of people is like
what you do where I was like be James if
you get what I mean it's like you've
sort of done that through sharing people
like what your plans are and like this
is why I want to do build more
relationship you I'm building a team
there's for my progression and people
probably do a lot of that they be
personal in the meetings I'm fighting
but then they don't they they don't
they're not personal online yeah that's
where everyone's missing a trick supply
thing the things that do the best on
LinkedIn from myself in these things by
lot froze on poor me putting a post I'll
start my own business like that that
gets loads of traction because people
respect that it's really personal
yeah yeah and then likewise your videos
like I think you come you you sort of
just be James I mean and I think anyone
listening that wants to start like that
is generally my best advice of this
always like just just actually but
people connect with a person and people
connect with James so give them James
yes and this easier said than done but
that's the secret like I think over for
over complicating massive II yeah we've
been talked about for moms and doing it
and I come back from a meeting and in
the meeting the client spoke about it
was I was about like a inspirational
leader yeah and I did a video on it me
and Jack was walking back for the
meeting video myself walking through
more game yeah I know
people's idea me evaluate so I mean I
there beforehand you don't really
necessarily think people aren't gonna
listen you don't think they're gonna
listen that much yeah and one guy
Malcolm
years he's like comments on everything
like yeah keep up the good work in the
content like before you didn't think
anyone would ever communist mother yeah
that's that I love the fact that you're
getting some wins off it and I think
keep it on me so look basically James a
question I always like to ask I think
I'm actually gonna start changing this
and actually asked like new questions at
the end like five questions but quick
basic questions yeah basically it for
our questions but basically the question
I always do like to say mate is a lot
obviously if you could and if you could
communicate every single recruiter out
there they listen to James Dean like
they'd implement your advice tomorrow
what what spring someone it could be a
phrase a word I said earlier you know
this means you can control things you
can't control down on what you can't
control
well you can't control I was sorry I
forgot to ask actually what and make
great advice I think what I wanted to
say was before we finish what's what's
going on in your world you excited about
I forgot to wanna sorry would you know
we asked you to the beginning no I was
in like just at the end oh no I did not
I hadn't forgot I just normally other
normally I'd to ask you that question
the end yeah and I normally before that
say tell me about your life James what's
going on so fillers inmate what's the
latest what were you excited about oh
yes yeah the moment like business is
obviously crazy well the moments mainly
work-related
yeah I'm just doubling down and work
with I'm gonna road to directorship at
the moment hopefully point in video
hopefully if I do if I do well that's
exciting all right sir that's exciting
getting close to the Audi alright mate
yeah it's funny that I said earlier they
me drive something I put it on the off
street parking the photos we Instagram
yeah yes pretty much that may lie I'm
just yeah it works really crazy busier
moment which is exciting and quite
boring really I wish I have more to tell
you not real cream food team but yeah we
are yeah no we've got yeah so we were a
chap means you say humphy yeah but yeah
at the moment it's just like just
spelling roles for fun I'm sorry really
it's just that's exciting yeah it's
really good bye
I'm keen to hire people first for the
team as a business I think we're already
looking new offices because we need you
maxed out and that's my time see ya yes
it's not as good well thank you Tom it's
been a pleasure thank you Safari this
cheery